the animal kingdom has a very important
rule bright colors mean I will mess you
up and no creature in the sea says I
will mess you up more emphatically than
the brilliant nudibranch but this sea
creature is kind of a cheater it gets
its colorful defense from other animals
by eating them some eat corals and
others jellyfish stingers to what you
might say well I can't eat jellyfish
stingers that's because unlike a
nudibranch you don't excrete a special
mucus to protect your esophagus well at
least I hope you don't but even if you
did the stingers wouldn't make their way
through the wall of your stomach and end
up in your skin but with the nudibranch
they do and voila a previously
defenseless creature now packs a serious
punch not literally of course because
well no arms particularly powerful is a
species called the blue dragon which
steals the stingers of the infamous
Portuguese Man O'War so just like never
touch one of these but it gets even
better
some species slightly modify their
stolen defences leading to novel
compounds and many of these have
anti-inflammatory properties
unfortunately if you eat a nudibranch it
won't be like popping an ibuprofen also
it would be weird